today's one minute monday  is purpose have a purpose what are you  doing this for  if you're starting the business just  trying to make money you're never gonna  make it it's not gonna work you're gonna  quit  as soon as it gets hard you have to have  a purpose  if you look at the most successful most  famous entrepreneurs in the world they  started their business for a reason  they started their business to have an  impact somewhere to give back to make  meaningful change  they have a purpose until you discover  what your purpose is  and start living it you're never going  to have success as an entrepreneur  focus on your purpose believe  for those of you watching like the video  thumbs up below let me know what you  think leave a comment you have a  question i'll make a video response for  you  thank you so much and i'll see you soon